Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie
They just announced that Nicholas Hoult will be playing
the new DCU, Lex Luthor, starting in Superman Legacy
So we'll break it all down is a huge surprise.
I wasn't expecting him,
but I am actually pretty happy that they picked him.
some of you also may remember that he tested for
and failed to get the role of Superman.
So. A failed super hero
winds up turning into more of a villain in the DCU.
Which sounds exactly
like what happens to Lex Luthor in the comics.
he thinks of himself as the hero of his own story
when in reality
he winds up turning into a really big villain.
so the Batman Dark Knight adage holds true.
A failed superhero now becomes the villain of the story
Funny how that wound up working out.
So if you're breaking into the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
They're getting ready to start filming Superman Legacy.
So we'll start learning about more of the cast,
more the actual story,
it will probably get a little bit of footage
from the actual movie.
But James Gunn did say he's like,
There's no way I'm going to be revealing exactly
what his Superman costume is going to look like.
personally,
I do not think it's going to go down like that.
I think that somebody somehow,
somewhere will wind up leaking
what some of the costumes with some of the characters,
what everything winds up looking like.
if he couldn't stop some of that stuff from getting out
when he was at Marvel
doing the Guardians of the Galaxy movies,
he's probably not going to be able to do it
when he's doing his DC movies.
but one of the major differences in Nicholas Holt's
new version of Lex Luthor from previous incarnations,
like Jesse Eisenberg's
DCU version in Man of Steel, Batman v Superman.
Justice League.
Kevin Spacey's version.
Gene Hackman's version
is that Lex Luthor won't start out in Superman Legacy
being the main villain,
at least in this first new Superman legacy movie.
I think the idea is that James Gunn is letting
his character cook a little, so to speak.
Like, what is he cooking in
a more Michael Rosenbaum, Lex Luthor kind of way.
so that over time, gradually he'll become the main
villain of one of the new Superman sequels in success.
Like assuming that they do wind up
making a trilogy of new Superman movies.
So James Gunn was casting Nicholas Hoult with the idea
that he'd be playing the character in the upcoming
new versions of the Justice League movies,
whatever those wind up being in any other big
crossover movies that they want to use the Lex Luthor
character in, he's going to be huge.
it'll be a way bigger role than just being a minor
antagonist in this new Superman movie
while I was making this video,
they literally also just announced
that Sarah Sampaio
is going to be his new Miss Tess marker.
So Miss Tess Marker will be with him in the movie.
if you didn't realize Nicholas Hoult did screen test
for Superman previously.
But I think what really happened earlier this year
before the strikes all went down
is that James Gunn was secretly screen testing Nicholas
Hoult for chemistry with David Cornes with Superman.
So their unusual relationship
as opposites turned enemies
eventually worked on screen
as they developed that over the next couple of movies.
even though I love Henry Cavill's version of Superman,
I feel like he didn't quite
have the same kind of chemistry
that they should have had between him
in the Jesse Eisenberg version of Lex Luther,
and they didn't really have a lot of time to develop
that relationship between those two characters.
some of the stuff that Zack Snyder was working up to
with the Jesse Eisenberg of Lex Luthor
in those unmade Justice League two in Justice League
three movies would have been pretty epic, though.
I did a full breakdown of those movies a long time ago,
so I'll link that video at the end of this.
Zack Snyder was nice enough
to reveal the full plot of both of those movies.
He did have way bigger plans for his Lex Luther
creating an injustice society in a turn in this huge
arc across the Justice League sequels
so we think his version of Lex Luthor
would have gotten there
with the Henry Cavill version of Superman eventually.
I think James Gunn is just trying to start off
in Superman Legacy on a stronger
footing between those two characters
just on a chemistry basis.
most of you probably think of the BS character
from X-Men First Class movies.
When you're thinking of Nicholas Hoult in comic
book movies, he was a solid version of Beast.
But seeing as Kevin Feige and Marvel just brought back
Kelsey Grammer as Beast and said,
it looks like Marvel is going in
a completely different direction with all their X-Men
cameos in Deadpool three in Avengers Secret Wars.
So that kind of explains why Nicholas Hoult would be
looking to jump ship from Marvel and come to DC movies
especially considering it'd be like the next 10
to 15 years of DC movies like Lex Luthor
are obviously huge, huge character And for those of you
that don't really see him as a villainous,
kind of manipulative character, he has talked
about his love of playing characters like that.
Like he's done it a few times.
I spent a lot with him as a character.
He's very manipulative,
smart and cruel, but also makes sense
and is jockeying for position, as you say.
And within this court and using all the pieces
and people he can to to get the results he wants
some of you also might remember a couple of years ago
he had to drop out of the Mission Impossible movies.
He was originally going to play the villain role
that Esai Morales wound up playing
during Mission Impossible seven and eight.
So he was already going to play
much bigger villains on screen.
So when you're thinking about the character
in Superman Legacy, think of him more in these upcoming
DC movies, like multiple upcoming DC movies
is more like Michael Rosenbaum's Smallville, Lex Luthor
and when I say that, that doesn't mean he's
going to start out being like best friends
with Superman,
not knowing that he is Superman or anything like that.
It just means that he won't start out
being the world's biggest villain
and he won't start out
being a villain to Superman at all.
he'll just start out being a very powerful figure
in the world who gains notice of Superman
during the movie and through the events of the film
will grow to mistrust him.
until in future movies, he'll turn into a full blown
villain trying to destroy Superman.
fun fact, too.
James Gunn has also been really good friends
with Michael Rosenbaum in real life for a long time.
That's how Michael Rosenbaum
wound up in the Guardians of the Galaxy movies.
It's weird that they have not worked together more
some of you might also remember recently that
they talked about how he thought that his Lex Luthor
was one of the best versions of all time.
he's not wrong.
Michael Rosenbaum's Lex Luthor from Smallville.
Still one of the best versions of Lex Luthor.
I already talked a little bit
about the actual plot of Superman legacy.
James. Going to clarify a couple of plot points.
Like to say there's no Middle
Eastern terrorist plot in the film.
there was a very brief Middle
Eastern plot during Batman v Superman.
So like, they're completely swerving on having
something similar to that during Superman Legacy.
but he did not deny any of the other plot points
that were mentioned recently.
So a lot of the reported plot
sounds weirdly similar to My Adventures with Superman,
that new TV show is a great TV show.
Obviously,
the movie is going to be a little bit different.
It is similar to that plot, basically the idea being
that humans get their hands on Kryptonian technology.
Superman is alerted to its presence
by his Fortress of Solitude
because he starts
the movie not knowing a lot about his heritage.
He intervenes, thinking that the Kryptonian tech
can help him learn more about his heritage.
James Gunn did say that the big theme of the movie
will be Superman,
trying to reconcile his Kryptonian heritage
with his heritage on Earth.
Being a corn fed Kansas farm boy,
it kind of the same situation
during my adventures with Superman, where he grows up
not really knowing anything about Jor-El or Krypton
and then slowly learns through his ship?
But he hasn't quite entered it yet.
Hasn't got like the full info from the Kryptonian A.I.
that is Jor-El.
sounds like something similar happens at the beginning
of Superman Legacy, where he starts the movie,
he probably has a version of The Fortress of Solitude,
but he hasn't gotten the full info.
They also, strangely did the same thing
on the Smallville TV show, where he basically grew
up, got his powers and started to figure those out
and slowly developed this Superman identity.
then he started to learn all about Krypton.
His father, all the other big Superman villains
started showing up during the movie, General Sam Lane
and Amanda Waller will be big characters in reportedly
Michael Rooker will be playing General Sam Lane.
James Gunn did say that some of his Guardians of
the Galaxy actors would wind up in the new DC movies.
supposedly the authority is working for
Sam Lane and Amanda Waller.
They sent them to take the Kryptonian tech,
putting the authority at odds with Superman,
who probably don't trust him at first.
They already confirmed that Angela speaker, a.k.a.
the engineer, is going to be
one of the other antagonists in the movie.
but Brainiac will be the actual main
villain of the film.
Funny enough.
They're also doing a very similar plot
on my adventures with Superman Season two,
with Brainiac Inside Coming to Earth.
The only difference in the movie is
that Zod isn't going to be in it, or as far as we know,
that's not going to be in it.
some of the brainiac plot and Superman legacy
might be similar or based on some of the Geoff
Johns Brainiac storyline where he comes to Earth
already having stolen the bottle City of Candor
in a might helps out the Supergirl movie
that they're working on, too.
but I think part of the idea is that
Superman will learn more about his Kryptonian heritage
from his interactions with Brainiac,
who knows all about Krypton's and Kryptonians
as far as we know, though,
the new Supergirl isn't going to be in this movie,
and it's probably not going to wind up
being the one from the Flash movie,
as for Nathan Fillion's,
Green Lantern Hawkgirl Mister Terrific.
My assumption is that some of them are either
also working with Amanda Waller or know about what's
going on with Superman and just keeping an eye on him
and help him fight Brainiac during the movie
Green Lantern will probably get involved
just because of Brainiac arrival, too.
Like that's his whole thing.
Green Lantern Corps
protecting Earth's sector from space based threats.
the other thing you might have thought about, too,
is that the Green Lantern Corps
would have probably monitored
Superman's pod arriving on Earth years before this
in Green Lantern might have just been clocking him,
waiting to see what would happen.
As he grew up and developed his powers.
like, are you going to turn into a hero?
Are you going to turn into a villain
or are we going to need to deal with you?
But Because the movie's meant to take place
pretty early in Superman's career.
I think when things pick up, most of the world
hasn't learned that he exists yet.
And they'll have some minor adventure at the beginning
of the movie that will serve as his big public
outing where everybody sees him and what he can do.
in as a result of that, as you would expect,
there are a lot of huge reactions from the superhero
community and a lot of other people
like Lex Luthor to like Everyone is very wary of him.
Like, are you here to help us
or are you here to take over the planet?
I think through the course of the movie,
the idea is he's supposed to win over the trust
of some of these Justice League adjacent characters,
like Hawkgirl, for instance.
I wouldn't be surprised if Green Lantern also sort of
catches him up on Kryptonians just in general,
just because his Green Lantern ring
would have all that information in it too.
Like, here's the info dump on what happened to Krypton.
And because we're talking about Brainiac
showing up in these new DC movies.
Originally, if you remember, Henry Cavill mentioned
they were going to do
a version of Brainiac in His Man of Steel sequel movie.
we don't really know much about the plot or what
that was going to be.
Probably not too dissimilar from the more recent Geoff
Johns, Brainiac run
a lot of brainiac stuff in present day
references that run.
but most people nowadays when they think of brainiac
especially recently,
is the injustice version of the character
who was great.
If you haven't played those games,
I would recommend checking them out.
there was also a version of Brainiac
they did on the Krypton TV
show relatively recently,
but his origin was a little bit different.
There was this whole time travel plot,
any kind of in full treated Krypton and slowly
took it over from the inside,
and because we're referencing so much Smallville stuff
with the new version of Lex Luthor
in the way they develop his character,
the version that they did a brainiac on
Smallville was actually based more
on the original comic book version
that started out as a Kryptonian A.I.
that ran a mug
He was played by James Marsters from Buffy,
who played multiple versions of Brainiac
like Brainiac three than Brainiac five.
Maybe that'll also happen in the new DC movies too.
Or we see multiple versions of the character
because that's his whole thing,
is that he evolves every time he gets defeated.
But everyone posts all your Nicholas
Hoult reactions in the comments below.
I'll do more videos for the movie
when we get more details.
Like I said, they're going to start filming
pretty soon,
so hopefully we'll get some footage
from the actual said click
Here for my Loki Season three video and click here
to learn about the full plot of Justice League 2
and the Justice League 3 movies. It is crazy.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!